italienische ferrari 2009 das habe ich
nicht es gibt nichts mehr geht nicht
da muss jetzt die 1000 meter wieder nach
hause rennen einen tag oder nach röbel
ich hab keine ahnung ja toll
gerade haben sie auch schon zwei die
aber nicht mehr raus ich hole mir was
ist da kreisauswahl ist mein home point
habe ich ein
du hast du ein erdbrocken folgen ja ich
habe mich in bern ich habe mir diamanten
also erde ist es ist ja dann brauch ich
das einfach mit diamant blöcke weiter
danke ich gucke jetzt ein bisschen rum
leute damit ihr das jetzt sehen könnt
dahinter
hier haben wir den provozierenden ist
einfach diamant blick auf sein
grundstück geklettert
hätte ich auch machen können aber das
war dann doch ein bisschen zu beruf
irgendwie so bist du ja nicht ich mache
mich calida hat er erkannt und so 30 ich
hab's gesehen du grafenfamilie 3 ist
einfach so den diamanten sind
wie was baut den scheiß wer will sich da
ist mein haus bauen nebenbei hat er
jetzt elektrisches zeug oder anlage sich
zwei drittel arbeitet die arbeitet kein
engel wenn ich jetzt sterbe ich hab 33
level habe so viele ärzte bei mir nicht
auf andere grundstücke eigentlich glaube
ich nicht betreten oder aber ich schaue
betreten schon glaubens landes kaputt
macht schon seiten gut ich hab meins mit
geschützt für mal geschützter vom vortag
aber dass ihm geklaut worden
das geklaut worden der geschützte mehr
ich hab ich eigentlich manchmal da kann
irgendwie so ich bin mich haben die
aufnahme nachgeschaut tatsächlich
einschätzung der stehen dazu meine
getreidefeldern kleine nicht beschützt
aber noch matthias klar dass solche
fragen mal wissen wie genau es gibt doch
so ob sillian so kleinen genau wofür
sind erstmal die totems diese drei
keinen das glaube ich auch von diesem
formcraft motto was ihm am meisten
eine weitere solche euch glaubt ziehen
jetzt die nächste folge als ich stehe
bei 37 diamanten die ich jetzt schon
seit ins ausland gefahren dieser folge
wird bei mir ist gleich auch komplett
endlich bin dann ja genau weiß fragen
wollte wofür sind diese obsidian
eingerannt ich glaube bei dem von craft
irgendwann später kann man da so ein
kleines portal draufsetzen infos und
machen was genau das ist es irgendwelche
komischen lichtern die da rauskommen
nenne die komische lichter die rauskommt
ist diese emissionsrechte und die
dimension einem nix weil lange meint ist
diese blitz auf einen schießen also es
können auch nicht nur diese kleinen
lichter rauskommen und blitze auf die
schießen sondern es kann auch sein dass
da mal eine brennende fledermaus
rauskommt seine feuer fledermaus
brennende fledermaus ja sowieso ein
höllen fledermaus bekommt zum haus wenn
sie gut gelaunt ist damit gelautet wir
kommen gerne mal fies sein und so und
farben machen
ok so bei mir sie bei rechtshänder ich
bin gerade noch so freundlich genug
die 26 mill wer das geschrieben
vielleicht an seine leute aber die höhe
die war richtig ergiebig
ich lasse mir interessant wenn ich
diamanten durch habe ich noch kein
feedback bekommen dazu weil ich habe das
ja schon ein paar mal gemacht und man
schokolade
ich hab auch ich nehme gerade auch schon
recht viele eigentlich im voraus auf
obwohl das eigentlich wollte ich
eigentlich gedacht hat das lässt nicht
mache weil ich oft gedacht und so ist es
bei mir auch gerade also die folge die
ihr jetzt vor gestern gesehen habe weil
wir die auch vorgestern aufgenommen
ressort rät vorvorgestern so bleiben
das ist ein ganz konkretes ktv beute
erhalten deren aussagen auch ein
bisschen vernünftig eigentlich oder
ausparken ist da unten im boden ja auch
spaß kommt von grundschülern kannst du
dir 26 mal abholen kann kommen auf mein
grundstück dann kannst du die 26 nabel
abholen was würde ich das nicht will
dann war ja erst mal hier ich hab' ich
hab ja der hat er nur gehofft dass du
dann zu ihm kommen ist bei 17 minuten
wollte ich es noch gar nicht gleich
sympathisch sonst machen sie mal einen
stunden papst habe also ich war nicht
das waren keine setze ich immer so 30
folgen mit 15 minuten fahrt sondern
schon mal so 30 bis 40 minuten halten
es macht immer spaß
dann gibt's die diamanten gibt die ja eh
schon einmal hier aber wenn er ein
sprengstoff sonne noch diamant gefunden
gerade mal wieder
springt auf eingeschlagen ok dann
brauche ich nicht bedanken
dann sollte dank bei den anderen werde
ein breiter als ob hier noch eine
zukunft wenn nicht sogar nichts passiert
allein bei mir zugeguckt ich erde
geklappt hat oder bei mir wie ich
mittlerweile 41
ganz einfach hier komplett darauf
fokussieren könnte ich theoretisch
gefragt meinte der ist allerdings muss
auch für die unten machen wenn ich jetzt
wirklich der erde so mache dann ist das
natürlich jetzt habe ich nur drin
ich wollte mich eigentlich gerade
erlaubt würde das halt ja was sollte
sogar abreißen kaufen
das expand extra auf den widder weiter
ich würde ich lieber durchgehend auf
also von daher okay das ist erst am
nächsten folge aber nicht in gang
ja weil der supreme court jetzt einfach
mit weil ich hier nur mehr klappen will
ich bin mir grade rating kaufen das
erste erweiterungs das zweite
erweiterungs pack von cod black ops 2
ach so da habe ich mir gar keinen kopf
der mit beckers 2 gekauft aber ich hab
es ja glaube ich 20 stunden spielzeit
mehr auch nicht weil ihnen die reizt
mich dieses spiel nicht so bei bmw dreht
sich nicht alles gekauft wenn wir 3 war
das spiel das bisher am meisten gesucht
und habe nach fifa das box richtig black
ops aber ich glaube ich werde ich bin
einfach jetzt ein bisschen enttäuscht
einfach durch mp3 obwohl es eine menge
gezockt habe einfach jetzt von cod weil
dann ich habe nach mw3 mw2 gespielt für
komisch aber mit mw2 nicht mehr
zufrieden deswegen ich weiß nicht ob ich
mir das neue call of duty gerutscht
holen werde
ich habe gestern erstmal die
pressekonferenz davon als box wollen wir
coupé das hätte ich fast eingeschlafen
desaster mit denen und hass mit
gequatscht ja ich hab das dann auch ein
bisschen mehr vorgestellt ja da beide
tier auch komplett darauf legen können
er klopft und will und dann auf einmal
sehe ich heute morgen xbox kostet 1000
euro beladen ich soko 11.000 1000 euro
überhaupt nicht betrieben da kriegt man
kleinwagen gebrauchen
das ist richtig naja wenn 4000 auf einen
dreier
na ja auch einen scheiß sagen aber mein
auto ein bisschen teurer
ich hab mir auch neues zugelegt golf 5
die golf
das ist schon gut 30 03 gebraucht war
nicht neu also ich muß like about kaufen
das glaub ich würd mir als ich meine
handyrechnung noch 17
für junge endlich
21.30 was die welt erst von youtube kann
man da natürlich von millionen menschen
kann man sich natürlich schon ein
bisschen was also du kannst einfach
gekauft irgendwas dann schreibt es das
nummernschild krebst einfach drüber
weiße und schreibt halt drauf trotz
karte als normal dass das reicht so
genau
hinten geldgeil usern speaker so was
alles ja ich bin kann ich weiß nicht
alles schlecht machen so auf sondern so
ein golf gti oder auch mini cooper mini
cooper roadster es wenn schon weil das
ein bisschen sport edition die dann oft
schon mal ordentlich fährt unter der
motorhaube
ich lasse ich golf gti oder mini cooper
fassungslos park ich kenne mich da gar
neue extrem aus münchen
da kann ich nichts mehr youtube money
bekommt würde ich mir
italienische ferrari sind tausende
tausend hendl ich weiß echt ist der
deutschen nobelmarke war das tollste
deutsche auto was gibt audi audi benz
mercedes bmw
wir haben mit bands und mercedes gemacht
branche egal ich oder so forsche hast du
doch schon genannt es gibt einen könig
könig seit genau ist es nicht gegen die
schwedisch oder sowas
skandinavisches hörte sich deutschland
als das damals vom grand turismo
gespielt habe ich gucke jetzt nach ich
bin keine punkte von christian
koenigsegg gegründet in ängelholm
schweden ja mal alles geile kommt aus
schweden ein kraut caron
nicht irgendwie aus norwegen oder so als
bitte blitzschlag bei stark ins
grundstück ein und alles kaputt ist voll
einschlagen
hauptsache der ist so übel nett zu uns
nie wollte uns diamanten geben und sagt
bitte blitz erschlagen
das ist ein geben
ich könnte dir erst deswegen weil das
uns zum grillen dann das darfst du nicht
dass er seine kisten jährlich auf dem
server sind das die legitimiert hat also
ich darf nicht auf den server gehen weil
er nicht auf und deswegen nicht einfach
in meine kiss und ich gebe sie würden
bisschen später dann darf ich ja nichts
sagen bei der dritten folge oder so die
man aufnehmen und ich habe jetzt schon
einer 68 die erste samstag und ich hab
noch mal gefunden hatte so absolut diack
untergeht moment moment moment so 68
jetzt schon 70 also ich habe zähle also
ein steak wollen das jetzt schon 1 6 1 6
doch noch die folge jedoch drei minuten
jetzt ich glaube dann werde ich endlich
mit dem thema form arbeiten fertig sein
soll handys mag 15 minuten ein diamant
schon reichen weil ich brauche
eigentlich nur ein spitzer gar nicht ab
schon zwei diamanten und die wollte auch
verzaubern guten aus meinen vielen 16
habe ich noch aus den sechs jemanden 17
gemacht hast doch ich bin da nicht so
gierig ich schon
ja schon
ich weiß das ist keinem spiel finden
werde von daher mit ich glaube das
reicht dann aber auch mit dias finden
erstmals über 36 aber so gelungen
dagegen einfach welche ab ein paar ein
paar aber nicht übertrieben weil ich
muss das noch ein bisschen selten halten
zu meinen monopoly ich gebe aber
irgendwann was zurück was für dich
vielleicht wertvoll sein
das bin ich zwar nicht viel aber dass
die frage in reisen 1064 zum dritten hey
jungs cool kann man gebrauchen was ich
brauche erde diamanten films per dsl ich
will einfach nicht wieder losgehen bei
dem wetter arbeiten ich habe immer noch
keine rüstung beziehungsweise
regenmantel gebastelt das ist traurig
regenmantel regenmäntel es gibt alles
merkel
ist genommen vieles zeug was wir nicht
haben die hab ich ja nur auf monkey
spezialisiert von bastl crafter fehlt
noch sehr viel zeug also leute es gibt
eigentlich diese regel dass man
innerhalb von hundert glocken von der
stadt hier nicht abbauen darf aber ich
baue hier erde ab und ich baue die erde
einfach so ab damit schön aussieht und
für ethischen bereich darf man übrigens
abbauen das haben wir gemacht zwei mal
kann es ähnlich genau kontrollieren auch
später met wo man sie jetzt gerade
befindet man darf halt oben auf den
grundstücken für anwendungs abbauen also
und ethisch belastet von anderen und
schickt runde gegen die als abort
deswegen dass das eher nicht aber halt
außerhalb der stadt zwischen den 100
blöcken entfernung und der stadt darfst
du auch unterhalb abbauen weil er meinte
ja gerade dass ich unter einem
grundstück gegeben davon jahr
durchschlag ich dabei eine rein zu
träumen kannst du woanders kannst du
eine papa gehen theoretisch habe sich
jetzt in meinem haus gemacht weil ich
zuvor war die pampa zulauf und jetzt
wieder diamanten geworden heilige
scheiße
na ja ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt
einfach so ein konkreter diamanten
fehler den beuchert jede folge oben
rechts ein
wie viel das relativ einfach weil das
ist einfach eine jpg-datei die ich
einfach die ganze zeit einteilen muss ja
mittlerweile sind es schon nach scheiße
ich könnte todes zähler einbauen dass
wir interessante 95 diamanten in diesen
drei folgen die spitzhacke ich habe
keine ahnung was ich noch so viel mit
ihm machen soll die nicht also der
aktion finanzplatz okay jetzt kommen die
intellektuellen gegenargumente
gegenbesuch links daten
aber irgendwas macht gemacht habe
einfach nur gebote von mahdia haufen vor
mir gibt kann das verstehen so ein
glückspilz
nee ich kann sehr finden eigentlich
theoretisch das war einfach so so ganz
plötzlich anlagen die vor mir so
ungeplant es gibt sich auch rucksäcke wo
du einfach alles rein tun kannst dann
müsste mich erst mal an den eindruck da
guckt man sie auch aber der den musste
kann den kannst du nur durch diese
bienenzucht machen weil da so sei der
brauch zu sein soll